stell dir eine stadt mit mehr als 80
millionen einwohnern vor das ist die
gesamte bevölkerung deutschlands aber
konzentriert auf einer fläche von der
grösse kroatiens nun eine solche stadt
gibt es zählt in china und ist als
greater bay area im berühmten herr
flussdelta bekannt dabei handelt es sich
eigentlich nicht um eine stadt sondern
um neun städte die in einem ballungsraum
sehr nahe beieinander liegen viele von
euch werden schon eine ungefähre ahnung
haben wovon die rede ist gesprächen von
jenem ort an dem shenzen um deinem job
zu finden sind und natürlich auch
hongkong und macao mit anderen worten es
geht um das chinesische silicon valley
der ort an dem sich die creme de la
creme des chinesischen high tech
befindet
[Musik]
und ich weiß dass du sagen willst marco
sturm ist aber ein wenig du hast am
anfang von einer megastadt besprochen
und jetzt erzählst du uns dass es sich
eigentlich um viele verschiedene städte
handelt die dicht beieinander liegen so
gesehen könnten wir auch klickt mäßig
behaupten ganz china sei eine megastadt
aber die wahrheit ist dass es sich hier
um einen absoluten sonderfall handelt
wir sprechen hier von mehreren städten
die nicht nur sehr nahe beieinander
liegen sondern auch die gleiche
infrastruktur nutzen gemeinsame straßen
gemeinsame buslinien und sogar eine
gemeinsame u-bahn chinas vision ist
nämlich dass die bewohner der greater
bay area diese megalopolis in nur einer
stunde von einem ende zum anderen
durchqueren können mit anderen worten es
wäre ein neues silicon valley nur größer
moderner und mitten in jener region
dieses planeten die so stark boomt wie
keine andere die frage ist also wo ist
das problem
ich bin mir sicher dass einige von euch
schon jetzt wie will kommentare
schreiben wie wiso als politik lässt
schon wieder kein gutes haar an ihr da
seid ihr so neidisch dass china reich
und wohlhabend geworden ist nun damit
haben wir ganz und gar kein problem im
gegenteil alles was neue polen der
innovation und wohlstand schafft ist gut
für uns egal ob in china mecklenburg
vorpommern oder timbuktu für diejenigen
unter euch die shopping fans nicht um
dieses video sehen haben wir viele
videos in denen wir die guten seiten
chinas hervorheben und wenn du uns schon
von anfang an verfolgt weißt du dass wir
die guten seiten china schon gezeigt
haben als es noch gar nicht in mode war
aber konzentrieren wir uns lieber auf
unsere geschichte
[Musik]
wir finden die great barrier ist ein
großartiges projekt aber was wäre wenn
die kommunistische partei chinas das
ganz anders sehen würde was wenn diesmal
nicht die querulanten sind unterschied
epping um es klar zu sagen die
beziehungen zwischen dem kp chef und
chinesischen geschäftsleuten wird immer
schlechter wobei das doch die
untertreibung des jahrhunderts ist jack
mast erste lektion in sachen business
china hat nur einen führer tja dann
hätten wir dann noch den evergreen
skandal der peking so einige
kopfschmerzen bereitet und das sind nur
zwei beispiele die es bis in die
westlichen mainstream schlagzeilen
geschafft haben die spitze des
sprichwörtlichen eisberg sozusagen auf
der ski seine sprichwörtliche
fahnenstange errichtet hat die
springende frage ist daher bis wohin
reicht deren ebenso sprichwörtliches
ende nun wortwörtlich müssen wir
feststellen ließen bringen will in china
große und wettbewerbsfähige unternehmen
haben aber bitte nicht so groß dass sie
ihn überschatten und auch nicht so groß
dass sie noch weiter die ungleichheit in
china verschlimmern die momentan ja
rasant wächst die eigentliche frage die
wir uns heute stellen lautet also
inwieweit stellt das projekt gateway
eine risiko für shipping da wird es die
regionalen unterschiede in china weiter
vergrößern heute werden wir all diese
fragen beantworten bevor wir jedoch dazu
kommen müssen wir euch noch schnell
unseren sponsor vorstellen surfen ibm
ein wirklich sicheres vpn dass jeder
datenverkehr noch meter oder
verbindungsdaten mit lok und außerdem
jede menge security tools mitbringt so
stark ist aber auch aus vielen anderen
gründen ein ganz tolles dpa natürlich
könnt ihr mit dessen hilfe auf websites
und internet dienste zugreifen in dem
land in dem er gerade seid nicht
verfügbar sind ohne zensur und joachim
ob daheim oder im urlaub darüber hinaus
bietet ist jedoch weitere
sicherheits-features habt ihr nicht zum
beispiel auch ein mulmiges gefühl durch
die allgegenwärtigen gerne boxe und
cookies mit zuschlag bekommt ein
handliches tulln am screen web dass sie
alle bloggt und die damit verbundenen
gefahren beseitigt aber nicht nur das
mit nur einem surfer konto könnt ihr
alle eure geräte im vpn registrieren
handys notebooks oder sogar eurem smart
tvs denkt wirklich alle arten von
geräten ab ihr bekommt damit einen
lückenlosen schutz von weil wir euch
unsere tollen fans lieb haben waren wir
nur bereit dieses sponsoring zu
übernehmen
serge hat auch einen ordentlichen rabatt
eingeräumt und das ist uns gelungen mit
hilfe des rabattcodes politik.de bekommt
ihr sage und schreibe 83 prozent rabatt
und obendrein noch die ersten vier
monate gratis dazu also nichts wie los
ihr solltet euch sourcag und hilft damit
gleichzeitig auch uns damit weiterhin so
nette videos wie dieses liefern können
so und jetzt lasst uns schnell ins plus
delta reisen
[Musik]
das chinesische silicon valley
jeder weiß ist das silicon valley auch
keine stadt sondern ein großer
ballungsraum dass mehrere städte umfasst
es ist ganz normal dass jemand zum
beispiel in palo alto und jeden tag in
den google büros in mountain view zur
arbeit geht und sich abends mit freunden
in einer bar in cupertino trifft und
wenn du dir das silicon valley auf einem
satellitenbild ansiehst ist ist fast
unmöglich zu sagen wo eine stadt aufhört
und wo die nächste anfängt es handelt
sich um ein durchgängig bebautes gebiet
in dem mehr als drei millionen menschen
leben und in dem es viel geld viele
talente und viele viele erfolgreiche
unternehmen gibt aber warte ein moment
denn das silicon valley ist nicht die
einzige megalopolis der welt in die
niederlanden gibt es zum beispiel die
sogenannte run statt einen ballungsraum
der amsterdam rotterdam und den haag
umfasst wenn du dir eine karte an siehst
du wirst du sehen dass es fast unmöglich
ist die einzelnen stadtgrenzen zu
identifizieren auch die randstad ist
eines der größten zentren der welt zur
innovation und wohlstand
und das great barrier oder gbr wie der
sich von nennen werden ist dasselbe nur
in china und wie viel größer was ist
also so besonders an gm was wir dort
produziert nun pass auf der iss gbr
wurde im laufe der geschichte eine immer
wichtigere regionen
seine häfen waren verschiedene eine
basis zu den außenhandel tatsächlich
flossen fast alle ausländischen
investitionen den 1990 er jahren in
china getätigt wurden überdies regionen
vergiss nicht dass hongkong kinos tor
zum rest der welt ist um die eine
vorstellung zu geben das gbe trägt heute
zwölf prozent zum chinesischen
bruttoinlandsprodukt bei wäre es ein
land würden wir die zwölftgrößte
wirtschaftsmacht der welt für uns haben
das heißt es der eher reiche als spanien
australien und das riesenreich russland
es überrascht daher auch nicht dass
diese region die höchste konzentration
von chinesischen fortune 500 unternehmen
aufweist darüber hinaus befinden sich
hier drei der zehn wichtigsten häfen der
welt wie du dir vorstellen kannst was
angesichts des erfolgs dieser region nur
eine frage der zeit ist die regierung
sie ins rampenlicht rückt um ihre
entwicklung weiter voranzutreiben
china stellt entwicklungsplan für
quantum hongkong macau great barrier vor
im februar 2009 10 hat die regierung
einen entwicklungsplan für die gwe
vorgelegt und fragst dich vielleicht
welche ziele wir sie damit erreichen das
hauptziel ist es eine infrastruktur zu
errichten um die neun städte perfekt
miteinander zu vernetzen dh man kann in
guangdong wohnen jeden tag in china
sensor arbeit gehen und den forschern
seinem tai chi kurs besuchen aber nicht
nur das china will auf eine gemeinsame
datenplattform für das gesamte team
aufbauen über welche art von daten reden
wir jeweils nun denkt dran dass china
reden eine hyper technologische diktatur
den mit gesichtserkennung kameras
polizeikontrollen und allen arten von
überwachung daten über ihre bürger
sammelt die idee dahinter ist dass die
behörden all dieser städte all diese
daten miteinander teilen ich weiß das
hört sich nicht sehr gut an aber denkt
an dass china nicht bereit ist ein
wohlstand um den preis des controls
tálos über seine bürgerinnen und bürger
zu erlangen aber das ist ein thema ein
anderes video zusammengefasst peking
strebt in gbr drei ziele erstens die
reisezeit zwischen den städten auf
maximal eine stunde zu schrumpfen
zweiter ist eine allgemein hohe
lebensqualität zu erreichen und drittens
innovation und technologie zu fördern
dafür liefert die technologie und
hongkong liefert das geld und ich weiß
dass einige von euch denken weil
diejenigen die nicht gerade fenstern
jinping sind der wird das geld
aufbringen reden wir hier über 100%
staatliches projekt nun die antwort
lautet nein schaust dir an
chinas alibaba für für die great barrier
über startup frau anna und du wirst
sagen okay das ist ja alles schön und
gut aber wohin sollte das ganze geld
hinfließen nun laut einer studie der
ages pc liegen die wichtigsten
prioritäten im moment bei der
kapitalisierung und börseneinführung ein
unternehmen der gewinnung von talenten
und dem bau von büros und die
wichtigsten sektoren das geld investiert
werden soll sie den technologie finanzen
und export im moment scheint alles
darauf hinzudeuten dass der gpl projekt
gute funktionieren
[Musik]
gehen eine führende pekinger universität
spricht mit einigen der teck absolventen
und fragte ob sie nach shanghai ziehen
wollen oder ob sie in the great barrier
ziehen wollen du wirst sie in shenzen
sehen georgia geschäftsführender partner
mckinsey büro dpa mit anderen worten das
gdi ist eine fantastische idee wir haben
nicht das geringste problem damit aber
vergiss nicht dass wir über china
sprechen und die prioritäten der
kommunistischen partei chinas reichen
manchmal ein wenig von unseren eigenen
ab hier kommt nämlich die dunkle seite
der ganzen geschichte ins spiel und die
werden wir uns jetzt ansehen
1 china der zwei geschwindigkeiten
[Musik]
wenn wir sagen dass china wächst als
gäbe es kein morgen sprechen wir nicht
wirklich über ganz china in wirklichkeit
hat sich die chinesische entwicklung auf
drei ganz bestimmte regionen
konzentriert den raum peking den raum
shanghai und dgb dort befinden sich 70
prozent der chinesischen fabriken wenn
wir uns jedoch ins landesinnere bewegen
finden der region vegan zu die das
pro-kopf-einkommen von ländern wie kenia
oder pakistan haben dürfen einen blick
auf diese karte
[Musik]
sein dass der auch diese region wachsen
aber die kluft zwischen dem reichen
china und dem nicht zu erreichen china
wird immer größer das muss natürlich
keine schlechte nachricht sein in
wirklichkeit wird ihn dass ungleichheit
daher dass die wohlhabenden gebiete so
schnell wachsen wie nie zuvor und die
anderen zwei aufwachsen aber halt nicht
so schnell da wäre jedoch noch eine
klitzekleine kleinigkeit erinnerst du
dich noch dunkel daran dass china
eigentlich eine kommunistisches land
sein soll der neue slogan von schiegl
pin lautet nämlich gemeinsamer wohlstand
oder wohlstand für alle dh erst jetzt im
jahr 2021 macht sich die gesamte
kommunistische partei chinas dran die
ungleichheit zu bekämpfen und sie haben
allen grund dazu sich sorgen zu machen
die folgendes vor ein mann der eingang
zu einer der ärmsten regionen chinas
lebt wenn dieser mann sich mit einem
anderen mann vergleicht eine chance'
erlebt wird er wahrscheinlich neidisch
sein und nein in diesem fall gibt es
keine zensur ich meine du kannst ihn
daran hindern nachrichten aus dem
ausland zu sehen dafür gibt es zum
beispiel die große chinesische cyberwar
weil diese in anderen videos gesprochen
haben auf sich der kommunistischen
propaganda könnte es sogar gut sein dass
er einen gewissen neid auf amerikaner
und europäer verspürt damit er noch mehr
und noch mehr verschüttet und china
genauso reich macht schließlich gehört
das schüren von neid und hass auf einen
äußeren feind zum agitation
propagandistischen einmaleins jedes
gewichten diktators das letzte was
peking will ist jedoch interne
spannungen in china zu erzeugen und das
erklärt nachrichten wie diese
chinas ehrgeizigstes projekt die neue
seidenstraße
das ist richtig die pings neue
seidenstraße auf englisch mann bedroht
verfolgt gleich zwei ziele das erste ist
uns allen gut bekannt wenn westliche
medien berichten ausgiebig darüber die
schaffung einer riesigen handels
infrastruktur die china mit der ganzen
welt vernetzt das zweite für den
innenpolitischen machterhalt akp noch
wichtigere ist jedoch weitaus weniger
bekannt infrastrukturen wachstum für die
ärmsten regionen chinas die rede ist von
infrastrukturprojekten wie diesen
china startet den ersten vollständig
elektrifizierten hochgeschwindigkeitszug
in tibet diese
hochgeschwindigkeitstrasse würde tibet
mit citroen verbinden es war der ärmste
region des landes liege nun in den
genuss eines der modernsten züge der
welt kommen werden mit anderen worten
hier gingen will ein teil des in
reichlichen erwirtschafteten wohlstand
eine weniger wohlhabenden regionen
verteilen ob das ausreicht und die kluft
zu schließen ist eine andere frage
zurzeit muss du nur einen blick auf
einem satellitenbild werfen um zu sehen
wo die dichtesten straßennetze liegen
egal wieviel im armen china in die
infrastruktur investiert wird das
südosten des landes bekommt den
löwenanteil ab noch einmal ist das
wirklich ein problem nun im prinzip nein
aber eines ist sicher wenn das reichlich
jena weiterhin so schnell wächst wie
bisher könnte ist politisch zu mächtig
werden so sehr dass es die kings
autorität herausfordern könnte die
unternehmen im perlflussdelta seien
zudem auch sehr gut mit taiwan verlässt
von go häufig viel know how kommt aber
warte ein moment denn das ist nicht die
einzige herausforderung die auch
shipping zukommt
das füße und das so
der slogan gemeinsamer wohlstand oder
wohlstand für alle umfasst weit mehr als
die überwindung der regionalen kluft es
geht auch darum die kluft zwischen arm
und reich zu überwinden jean ping
misstraut seinen geschäftsleute
zunehmend weil er befürchtet dass sie zu
viel macht haben und dass sie too big to
fail sind also unternehmen die so viel
macht haben dass sie das ganze system
beeinträchtigen könnten vor kurzem gab
es ja den fall ever great der vielen von
euch bekannt sein dürfte es handelt sich
dabei um ein riesiges jesus
immobilienunternehmen das millionen und
abermillionen von dollar an
zinszahlungen nicht zu bezahlten der
lage war er wegrennt hat sogar albträume
über einen möglichen lehman brothers
moment auf dem finanzmarkt wach gerufen
und viele werben nun sagen dass dies ein
klares beispiel dafür ist die sehr
schlimm doch recht hat es ist ein fehler
dass private unternehmen so viel macht
besitzen aber schauen wir uns das doch
mal etwas genauer an diese medaille hat
in china nämlich zwei seiten ja es sind
gigantische konzerne mit extremer macht
entstanden auf der anderen seite übt die
chinesische regierung jedoch auch viel
kontrolle über die wirtschaft aus wir
dürfen nicht vergessen dass sich die
wichtigsten ethischen banken im
staatsbesitz befinden und nicht nur das
shipping will diese gewaltige staatliche
kontrolle noch weiter ausbauen
die umsetzung all dieser anti monopol
vorschriften ist absolut notwendig um
die sozialistische marktwirtschaft zu
verbessern und den gemeinsamen wohlstand
zu fördern skijumping wohlstand für alle
ist ein sehr klares ziel war jeder
gelegenheit nicht müde wird zu
wiederholen wobei er andeutet das
technologieunternehmen und ihre
millionenschweren unternehmer als
konkurrenz zur politischen und sozialen
macht und china gesehen werden um die
regierung angreifen und genau aus diesem
grund er lässt die regierung zurzeit
drastische vorschriften die gegen diese
unternehmen gerichtet sind wie im falle
ali babas oder sogar maßnahmen wie die
strikte begrenzung der spielzeit der
chinesische scannt mit den videospielen
der großen online gaming konzern
verbringen darf es geht darum exempel zu
statuieren die zeigen sollen dass in
china jeder nach den regeln der
kommunistischen partei spielen muss aber
nicht alles ist schwarz und weiß der
präsident weiß genau dass er seine
geschäftsleute auch unterstützen muss
sie mir mal das an sie plant neue börse
in china um kleine unternehmen zu
fördern richtig china plant die gründung
einer neuen börse in peking kapital zu
beschaffen und kleine unternehmen zu
fördern wir haben zwar gesehen dass die
regierung lieber ihre staatlichen
unternehmen finanziert die von kp
mitgliedern geführt werden aber sie weiß
auch dass sie mit privaten unternehmen
hand in hand gehen muss aber was hat das
alles eigentlich mit dem wwe zu tun nun
eine ganze menge wir reden hier über
eine region die bereits hoch entwickelt
ist aber noch viel weiteres potenzial
hat es ist nur logisch dass peking ihre
infrastruktur weiter ausbauen und so
könnte leicht einen neues silicon valley
entstehen aber vergesst nicht dass das
ursprünglich amerikanische silicon
valley auch enormen politischen einfluss
hat die frage ist also wie viel macht
ist shipping bereits zu opfern um das
wachstum dort anzukurbeln glaubst du die
kommunistische partei chinas wird den
gba unternehmer niemals vertrauen oder
wird sie weiter versuchen einen weg zu
finden sie vollständig zu kontrollieren
wie immer sind wir auf eure meinungen zu
diesem thema hochgradig gespannt ich
hoffe also dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat falls ja gibt uns mit einem
like kaltes und freunde und vergesst
nicht das abo mit glöckchen um keines
unserer videos mehr zu verpassen was gut
und bis bald
[Musik]